I saw you write something about dull
bits and a script and I'm curious what
that means yes a Hitchcock has one of my
favorite quotes which and not let's see
if I for all of those who are Hitchcock
aficionados forgive me if I don't have
it exactly right but it's something to
the effect of movies are exactly like a
real life but with all the dull bits cut
out and essentially if you think about
films you are lying
movies are lies so let's say you're
doing a story about Helen Keller or
Abraham Lincoln and let's say this band
whether it's takes place over a year or
takes place over a lifetime or 20 years
we're seeing a two-hour movie generally
speaking now in half two hours a little
more
it's a consolidation of real life so you
have to cut out the dull bits so this is
also I would say a common mistake that I
see with writers is that the need to
explain the entrance into a scene and
the and leaving we don't need to see
characters Oh walking into a door
walking down the hallway unless of
course it's very purposeful like you're
doing a thriller and someone's walking
down a hallway and there may be someone
in another room that they don't know
about so that's there it's very
purposeful but we don't need to see a
character entering and saying hi oh I
just came in from the grocery store
we don't need to play that scene out and
then see they carry Joe say okay I'm
leaving now I'm exaggerating a bit but
there have their scripts that I've read
where every scene practically starts
with the character entering and exiting
another example would be if we see a
husband and wife and they are heading to
the end loss we don't have to see them
get in the car put the kids and there
are a little you know and the seat belts
and the baby
seat drive the full distance obviously
or even part of the distance and we see
them get out of the driveway walk up the
door ring the doorbell
so that's an example of you cut out
deliberately those dull bits law and
order sometimes I'll say to writers
think of the law and order edits so you
may have a scene where one of the you
know one of the detectives says so do
you know about have you ever seen this
victim you know what the last time I saw
her she was partying with her friend
Jesse where do you find Jesse oh she's
always hanging out at such-and-such Club
boom we're at the club and sometimes we
might pick up a scene mid-conversation
so that's one example of cutting out
dull bits that's a great analogy I like
that do you think people get some of
that confused with novel writing yes
okay and even in novels you don't always
have you know character entering and
entering but exiting but in with novel
writing one of the things that you can
do is get fully inside the head of your
character so she's walking down the
street and she sees a leaf and it
reminds her of when she was young this
is I can factor and lost her virginity
and we don't have the luxury in scripts
you can of course do well fantasy
sequence or flashback but generally
speaking you can't do go on and you
can't as like in a book you can describe
smells in a movie you can't really
describe a smell you could say that
character burns toast and there's smoke
coming out of the toaster but so it
definitely has to be much more
economical and one of the things I said
a lot I was an English major where my
greatest teachers was Shakespeare and
wanted
say that is that of course add wonderful
teachers who were guides but one of the
greatest teachers is reading great
authors great screenwriters great
playwrights I talk about a lot of times
with writers getting them feedback about
not writing with exposition Harold
Pinter is a master of subtext I
recommend Mathieu whiner
and that Mad Men characters rarely say
exactly what they're feeling there's so
much subtext and it just makes the
writing that much more powerful do you
think the the lost art of novel reading
will come back i I don't know if I feel
it's that lost even though Barnes and
Noble
sadly is you know closing and but I
think they're just so many wonderful
books out there and I know so many
people who are in book clubs and I J K
Rowling bless her I mean she is
responsible for getting more people more
children into reading and there's so
many great authors out there and of
course as we know books are a great
great source for for movies Hollywood
loves intellectual properties they like
source material it's another strategy
sometimes with screenwriters they have a
script and it's well written and it
they've been having a hard time for
whatever reasons gaining traction
sometimes them they may turn it into a
book and if the book starts to get
traction then they sort of
reverse-engineer and go back and then
sell it as sell the script sell the book
and the script based on the book
you